et siège au groupe l'est républicain et
vice-président du sénat bonjour philippe
dallier de bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin on va commencer par ce
mouvement social à la sncf et les
cheminots qui parle d'un droit de
retrait le gouvernement qui dénonce une
grève sauvage est ce que pour vous ce
mouvement social est justifié je pense
qu'on est clairement dans l'abus de
droit effectivement qu'un certain nombre
de questions se posent et que les
syndicalistes veuille en débattre il n'y
a aucun problème là-dessus par contre le
moyen qu'ils ont choisie qui pénalise
des millions de français au début des
vacances scolaires franchement ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas acceptable
voilà droit parce que le droit de
retrait il est quand même très encadré
et considéré que partout en france
effectivement pourrait stopper le
travail sans préavis
pour effectivement manifesté son
opposition à une situation et un
incident qui a été relativement grave je
n'en disconviens pas mais ceci étant dit
ce ne sont pas des méthodes et je rêve
du jour où dans ce pays on pourra avoir
effectivement un dialogue social et des
relations employeurs salariés qu'ils
soient beaucoup plus apaisé responsable
que cela pour vous le gouvernement a
raison de parler d'une grève sauvage
c'est ça oui je pense qu'il a tout à
fait raison oui est ce que il faut
revoir vous parler de ce droit de
retrait c'est ce que les cheminots
invoque pour ce mouvement social est ce
que pour vous il faut revoir ce droit de
retrait faut revoir les conditions je
pense qu'il va falloir préciser les
choses alors je ne sais pas si
effectivement des procédures seront
engagés c'est ce que j'ai cru comprendre
dans la bouche de guillaume pepy est
également du premier ministre mais je
pense qu'à un moment donné il va falloir
clarifier les choses parce qu'on ne doit
pas pouvoir l'invoquer à tout bout de
champ pour désorganiser complètement le
pays ça ça n'est pas acceptable quand
vous dites je ne sais pas si les
procédures sont engagées ça veut dire
que vous vous êtes pour des sanctions
contre ces cheminots moi je pense qu'à
partir du moment où l'effectif c'est en
ami on a mis très longtemps dans ce pays
concernant les transports à obtenir un
minimum de choses et notamment un
service minimum et l'information des
usagers pour que chacun puisse réagir
avec un préavis de grève à partir du
moment où on détourne une procédure qui
a conduit à ce qu'on a pu constater ce
week-end ça n'est pas acceptable il ya
un moment où chacun prend ses
responsabilités si certains veulent
s'exonérer
de ce que leur impose la loi et la
réglementation il en assume les
conséquences
les cheminots qui manifesteront à partir
du 5 décembre contre la réforme des
retraites est ce que vous comprenez la
hausse il annonce de ce mouvement social
avant qu'on ne connaisse le détail de
cette réforme coutelle aux grottes de
droit de grève est garantie dans ce pays
et à partir du moment où effectivement
on va respecter un certain nombre de
procédures
il n'y a aucun problème là dessus mais
plus généralement sur cette réforme des
retraites
on voit bien comment le gouvernement est
très mal embarqué est d'ailleurs
vraiment le sentiment qu'il commence à
en prendre conscience et là il ya une
explication toute simple c'est que
pendant la campagne des présidentielle
en 2017 le président de la république
fin alors candidat n'a pas dit la vérité
aux français
il a d'abord dit il n'y a pas de
problème il pas nécessaire de toucher à
l'âge les régimes doit être équilibré
etc
on voit bien aujourd'hui que c'est faux
nous annonce 10 milliards de déficit
dans deux ans ou trois ans et puis après
on nous a vendu une réforme égalitaire
qui ferait quasiment pas de perdants et
beaucoup de gagnants et plus on creuse
et plus on s'aperçoit que ça n'est pas
possible ça n'est pas possible tant que
le gouvernement va maintenant se trouver
confronté à une très grande difficulté
c'est que les français aient
effectivement sont en train de se rendre
compte que cette réforme va faire
énormément de perdants donc voilà donc
on va se trouver dans une situation où
un avis extrêmement difficile occident
comprends bien vous ne tenez pas cette
réforme qu'il faille une réforme des
retraites c'est certain qu'il faille
cette réforme là des retraites ça c'est
autre chose parce qu'on voit bien
qu'elle est on sait que c'est difficile
je vais pas vous dire le contraire
les régimes spéciaux va bien falloir
traiter le problème à un moment donné
oui à leur suppression
bah je pense coup il faut aller vers
leur suppression parce que ça ça n'est
plus acceptable étant mené ce que ça
coûte et on ne peut pas continuer à
demander uniquement au secteur privé et
aux salariés en général de financer au
travers de leurs impôts le matière de
régime qui n'ont pour une grande
majorité des gens concernés plus de
raison d'exister
donc il faut aller vers une réforme mais
le gouvernement s'y est très mal pris en
n'ayant pas le courage d'expliquer aux
français qu' effectivement il va y avoir
des difficultés il va falloir travailler
plus longtemps donc là gouvernement
s'est piégé lui-même et voilà ce qui va
créer à mon avis
difficulté mais vous ne dites il fallait
pas cette réforme ça veut dire qu'il ne
fallait pas de réforme systémique qu'il
fallait uniquement touché aux paramètres
à la durée sans travail moi je pense que
il faut peut-être les deux mais si ce
n'est que ce régime par points qu'on
nous a vendu comme étant égalitaire le
même pour tous on voit bien qui il va
faire énormément de perdants et on a
aussi le sentiment c'est à peu près
clair qu'on va utiliser les réserves des
différents régimes pour venir j'allais
dire boucher le trou d autres au régime
et le gouvernement continue à prétendre
le contraire si ce n'est que les
français n'y croient pas et je n'y crois
pas non plus n'a pas dit la vérité
et maintenant il est coincé alors le
fait en plus on voit bien une réforme
aussi sympathique que celle là telle
qu'elle était présentée maintenant nous
annonce qu'elle sera présenté après les
élections municipales
écoutez le gouvernement et s'est fait
piégé lui-même et il va avoir du mal à
en sortir après les élections
municipales vous y croyez il y en a qui
ne croient pas à ce calendrier est ce
que vous vous dites oui elle sera
présentée avant l'été elle sera votée
avant l'été
tout est possible et plus on va
approcher de 2022 et moins la volonté
réformatrice de ce gouvernement sera
évidente on l'a déjà vu sur un certain
nombre de sujets et notamment sur le
budget qu'on nous propose donc vous
dites encore gouvernement par reculer
bien sûr qu'ils purent qu est le
gouvernement qui pourraient différés sur
le fond qui pourrait différer l'entrée
en application de cette réforme pour le
moment elle doit concerner la génération
née en 1963 ça pourrait être celle de 64
de 65 voire après est-ce que ça déjà
c'est un premier signe de recul pour
vous bien sûr que c'est un premier signe
de recul mais il va bien falloir
équilibrer ce que c'est quand même ça
l'objectif premier est bavard et de
monter un régime qui va pouvoir
permettre de ne plus générer de déficit
c'est quand même ça l'idée de départ et
on voit bien qu'avec la dégradation de
la situation et ces 10 milliards à
trouver d'ici 2 à 3 années il va falloir
toucher aux paramètres et le
gouvernement avait toujours dit qu'il
n'était pas nécessaire de toucher aux
paramètres
donc il ya une vraie difficulté elle est
l'autre sujet c'est ce débat sur le
voile hier bruno retailleau dans le
journal du dimanche pour nous intéresser
le patron des sénateurs les républicains
dit qu'il va déposer une proposition de
loi pour l'interdiction des listes
communautariste aux élections est ce que
vous soutiendrez cette position de la
côte et il y a
un vrai sujet c'est déjà le cas en
seine-saint-denis où don lors des
élections passées on a vu effectivement
fleurir sa tombe de liste ou deux
candidats qui manifestement n'a vait pas
en partage les valeurs de la république
la question sur ce sujet ça va être la
qualification juridique de ces listes ou
ses candidats et là c'est d'une extrême
difficulté et même lorsque nous
l'aurions qualifier je pense que
certains seront suffisamment habile pour
contourner le cadre juridique nous
aurons que nous aurons plus instaurer
donc il ya un vrai problème et bruno
retailleau a tout à fait raison de le
poser maintenant la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on va le traiter et ça
veut dire que ça promet si envoi ne
pourra pas se traduire dans les faits on
va regarder effectivement comment
juridiquement il est possible de le
traduire je souligne simplement qu'on a
une vraie difficulté juridique
à l'heure actuelle les conseillers
municipaux ne sont pas soumis à une
obligation de neutralité religieuse pour
vous il faut changer ça coûte et dans
l'espace politique
effectivement la neutralité religieuse
devrait s'imposer naturellement on voit
bien aujourd'hui que certains ne
l'entendent pas de cette manière là et
il y a un vrai problème pour notre
république c'est la république quand on
regarde un peu ce qui s'est passé dans
la fin du 19e siècle
ça a été un combat d'une extrême
violence on peut le regretter d'ailleurs
un à l'époque un combat d'une extrême
violence pour parvenir à ce consensus
qui a été trouvé en 1905 il faut
regarder l'histoire pour voir combien
les catholiques qui ont été à l'époque
effectivement se sont sentis stigmatisés
mais on est arrivés à un compromis mais
ce compromis est bon et il ne faut pas
qu'il puisse être remis en cause et le
sentiment et c'est plus que le sentiment
que nous avons aujourd'hui c'est que ces
machine arrière toute
et on se repose les mêmes questions on a
les mêmes débats il va falloir qu'on en
sorte
sébastien lecornu lui il parle de front
républicain locaux pour contrer assez
lisse communautaire est-ce que ça
finalement ce n'est pas la bonne méthode
il y à il ya longtemps que
qu'effectivement
j'ai émis le voeu que les grands partis
politiques de droite et de gauche ne
joue pas au moment des élections et
notamment des élections municipales avec
le communautarisme
parce que ça a pu arriver et de la part
de tout le monde je vais pointer
personne en général mais je vais
effectivement dire que à droite ou à
gauche certains ont plu au moment des
élections et notamment les élections
municipales parce qu'on veut bien que
c'est là que que le danger est le plus
important
certains ont pu jouer avec cela et ça
c'est le pire qui puisse arriver
donc j'espère effectivement donc front
républicain non pas trop ce que ça veut
dire mais en tous les cas il faut qu'il
y ait une prise de prise en compte du
problème qui nous est posée et que
personne ne joue avec cela l'autre
actualité sur ce débat sur le voile
c'est une proposition de loi là aussi un
des républicains de votre collègue
jacqueline eustache brinio qui vise à
interdire les signes religieux
ostentatoires aux accompagnateurs de
sorties scolaires ça fait suite à cette
polémique déclenchée par un élu du
conseil régional du rassemblement
national en bourgogne franche comté est
ce que interdire les mères voilées
durant les sorties scolaires ça c'est
une proposition de loi vous soutenez gvt
août d'abord je vais rappeler que le
sénat a re débattu de cette question là
avant même l'incident qui s'est produit
au conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté dernier en mai dernier
et pourquoi est-ce qu'on est amené à
rediscuter de cela c'est parce que
lorsque la loi sur les signes
ostentatoires à l'école a été adopté on
n'a pas eu le courage de trancher les
choses et c'est pire que ça on a tout
simplement dit bah écoutez les
directeurs et des riffs les écoles ou
les enseignants apprécieront ça sur le
terrain et gérons cela ce qui est d'une
grande lâcheté blanca ce qui est d'une
grande lâcheté parce que c'est leur
faire porter une responsabilité dont à
mon avis ils n'ont pas envie et qui dans
certains endroits peuvent effectivement
les mettre en difficulté donc il faut
que la loi précise les choses et moi
pour moi il est clair l'école de la
république ça doit être un sanctuaire
les sorties scolaires c'est du temps
scolaire donc à partir du moment où
c'est du temps scolaire je considère
qu'on doit être dans la neutralité la
plus absolue donc un t rex à
l'interdiction mai
une autre possibilité sans ré ouvrir ce
débat il suffit entre guillemets parce
que ça va avoir un coût de demander au
maire est bien de fournir les
accompagnateurs comme ils le font sur
les activités périscolaires et le vous
dire que ces sorties doivent être
encadrés par le personnel et le problème
est réglé
on prend des animateurs de centres de
loisirs et on en met deux trois
dispositions pour ses sorties scolaires
et le débat est clos
ça veut dire plus de mères
accompagnatrices de parents mais
l'accompagnement par les parents ce
n'est pas un droit inscrit dans la loi
c'est une facilité gratuite parce
qu'effectivement quand on emmène des
gamins à l'extérieur il ya des normes
d'encadrement à respecter et la facilité
c'était de demander à des parents
d'élèves de venir sur ce temps scolaire
mais à partir du moment où effectivement
l'encadrement se ferait par des
personnels des communes le problème est
réglé la neutralité s'impose très bien
philippe dallier on va changer de sujet
on va parler du budget l'assemblée
nationale examine en ce moment même le
budget en séance mais au sénat les
auditions ont commencé un pour examiner
ces budgets ministère par ministère on
va parler d'un budget que vous
connaissez bien philippe dallier c'est
celui du logement puisque vous êtes en
charge de ce budget hausse énorme en
parle avec notre journaliste
parlementaire alexandre tout ça bon j'en
regarde mon jean philippe dallier
bonjour alex en 2020 les aides
personnalisées au logement les fameuses
apps et elles vont baisser pour une
partie de la population
et oui les appels vont baisser pour
environ un million de français alors ce
n'est pas une coupe nette dans le
montant des appels comme ça avait été
décidée en 2010 est moins 5 euros en
2018 - 4 euros cette fois ci c'est une
réforme du mode de calcul de
l'allocation logement
alors concrètement à partir de 2020 la
location va être calculée sur les
revenus en cours et non plus sur les
revenus d'il ya deux ans comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
le gouvernement communique sur une
réforme de justice sociale car la
location va mieux correspondre aux
revenus perçus mais c'est aussi une
manière de faire des économies
au total 1,4 milliard d'euros
d'économies avec cette réforme car en
période de croissance mécaniquement les
revenus de certains français augmente
donc les allocations diminuent et l'état
fait des économies
alors cette réforme va faire des
gagnants et des perdants parmi les
gagnants
bien les personnes qui perdent leur
emploi leurs revenus chutent et donc la
location va augmenter automatiquement
et puis parmi les perdants il y a les
jeunes actifs ceux qui rentrent sur le
marché du travail
ils verront leurs revenus augmenter d'un
coup et donc la paix elle va chuter
immédiatement au total il y à 1,2
million de personnes qui vont voir leur
appel diminué et 600000 personnes
connaîtront la suppression de leur appel
une baisse de l'apl qui est donc
effective pour une partie significative
des français dans un budget 2020 que le
gouvernement appelle le budget du
pouvoir d'achat merci beaucoup l accès à
tout à l'heure
philippe dallier qu'est ce que vous
pensez cette réforme des appels je pense
qu'elle ne fera aucun gagnant elle ne
fera que des perdants parce que
aujourd'hui si quelqu'un qui bénéficiait
de la paix elle voit ses revenus
diminuer il a déjà la possibilité de
demander aux caisses d'allocations
familiales la réévaluation de ces appels
là on supprime la pl pour ceux qui
entrent effectivement dans la vie active
et c'était une aide à l'installation
quelque part et notamment pour les
jeunes puisque au moment où ils
trouvaient un emploi
et bien si on calculait l'apl sur les
revenus de l'année n - 2 effectivement
ce parfois l'isi avaient droit
souvent ils y avaient droit alors qu'ils
étaient peut-être au-dessus des plafonds
de ressources
donc on peut défendre le fait que dans
le cadre des économies budgétaires on
supprime cet avantage mais on ne peut
pas présenter ça comme une réforme de
justice sociale c'est tout ce que je dis
mais vous dites quand même vous ne le
contredisez pas le fait qu'il faut faire
des économies il faut bien faire quelque
part faire des économies c'est certain
mais si on regarde ce qui s'est passé
depuis deux ans sur la politique du
logement
le logement en général c'est le secteur
qui a contribué le plus effectivement
aux économies budgétaires de l'état
mais maintenant on va regarder le
connaissez la coriace trop ça veut dire
c'est bien à bad on sera dans certains
domaines bien évidemment trop et on va
s'en apercevoir quand on regardera les
chiffres de construction des logements
sociaux
tous ces chiffres sont en baisse donc il
ya un moment où le gouvernement
obtiendra des résultats qui
correspondent à la politique qu'il mène
mais d'un côté il nous dit il faut
construire plus parce qu'il ya un
problème de crise du logement dans ce
pays mais de l'autre côté toutes les
mesures qui sont prises pouces
effectivement un ralentissement de la
construction et le logement social qui
va être impacté le logement social et
déjà c'est certain mais il n'ya pas que
le logement social accession à la
propriété
on a supprimé l'accès à l'ass et la paix
l'accession on a supprimé le prêt à taux
zéro dans certaines zones
le pin l on sait pas trop ce qui va
devenir donc voilà il ya de grandes
inquiétudes
et pourtant le logement devrait être une
politique prioritaire dans ce pays
justement le gouvernement va lancer une
grande enquête sur le logement des
français pour disposer de statistiques
récentes pour dit-il pouvoir mener à
bien une politique efficace est est-ce
que ça c'est non mais c'est cette fois
ça me fait rire parce que une grande
enquête mais comme si on ne disposait
pas suffisamment dans ce pays d' enquête
qui permettent de connaître la situation
enfin je pense que tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet doivent rigoler
doucement voilà la situation on la
connaît maintenant il ya des bouts de
cette langue à deux ça ne sert à rien
c'est quoi ça le site n'en à rien c'est
le moyen le gouvernement voit bien
effectivement que tous les acteurs du
logement portent les mêmes critiques
donc voilà ils ont pris des décisions il
doit y avoir maintenant 4 milliards
d'économies budgétaires par an sur le
logement si ce n'est pas plus pour les
regarder longue détail et maintenant on
nous dit on va faire une grande enquête
pour écoutez franchement c'est ridicule
on voit que ça vous fait sur le budget
en général kg 10 est examiné à
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
alexandre le disais c'est invente un
budget du pouvoir d'achat neuf milliards
+ 2 9 milliards de baisses d'impôts pour
les ménages est ce que pour vous c'est
un budget qui va dans le bon sens on
redonne du pouvoir d'achat à certains
parce que là aussi il faut regarder les
choses dans le détail ça n'est pas
générale comme cela donc à certains mais
on le fait en creusant le déficit et la
dette
bon ben voilà c'est un choix du
gouvernement voit que l'objectif affiché
par emmanuel macron président candidat à
la présidence de la république était le
retour à l équilibre budgétaire à la fin
de son quinquennat tout ça c'est terminé
et on va voter un budget en déséquilibre
de 100 me dis comment les 200 milliards
le budget qu'on s'apprête à voter fac
l'assemblée nationale s'apprêteraient à
voter parce que nous n'avez doit le
voter revenu en deçà de la barre des 3%
mais un peu plus de l'année 3 % parlons
en euros on va voter un budget avec 400
milliards de dépenses et 300 milliards
de recettes le différentiel c'est 100
milliards
donc nous allons creuser le trou de 100
milliards et c'est comme ça qu'il faut
présenter les choses parce que ce pays
la dette publique a atteint 2400
milliards d'euros maintenant et nous
continuons effectivement à creuser ce
trou il ya un risque la dette de la base
de la barre des 100% initialement qu'un
canapé
arrêtons de parler de ces 100 % ou ses 3
% parce que tout ça finit par me par
occulter la réalité et la réalité c'est
que en cas de remontée des taux
d'intérêt ou en cas de nouvelle crise
financière
nous serons dans l'incapacité de payer
les intérêts de cette dette qui pourrait
passer de 38 milliards aujourd'hui à 80
milliards d'euros de manière très rapide
et là nous serions dans une situation
extrêmement difficile allez on va parler
de votre département et de la loi aussi
sur le statut de l'élu avec avec son
pousseur qui revient c'est la revue de
presse du département de la seine saint
denis
et alex on va commencer avec mais aussi
quand on a du parisien avec le parisien
et vous fait la une du parisien philippe
dallier dans sa rubrique
seine-saint-denis puisque vous êtes en
un peu en première ligne de la lutte
contre la vente d'alcool nocture qui est
un vrai problème en seine-saint-denis
avec notamment ses épiceries qui vendent
de l'alcool tard et avec ces
rassemblements alcoolisés bruyant qui
dérange les quartiers et vous avez la
semaine dernière fait passer un
amendement dans le projet de loi en
faveur des élus locaux qui permet aux
maires d'ordonner une fermeture
administrative de ces établissements qui
ne respectent pas la loi en matière
notamment de vente d'alcool et tous les
élus de seine-saint-denis ont salué
votre initiative quel que soit leur bord
politique car ils sont un peu démuni
face à ce fléau et on va regarder le
témoignage de votre successeur à la tête
de la commune de pavillons sous bois
katia copine qui raconte il ne se passe
pas un jour sans qu'on m'appelle à ce
sujet les épiceries vendent jusqu'à 2
heures du matin les gens par le très
fort font pipi contre les portes il y a
eu des coups de couteau et même une
tronçonneuse devant un bar à chicha
c'est épouvantable témoignage effarant
qui raconte le quotidien difficile de
nier le local sur ce sujet on en parle
avec vous philippe dallier mais d'abord
alex actu seine saint denis qui
s'intéresse aux lycéens et à
l'intelligence à huy à l'intelligence
artificielle encore un sujet qui vous
concerne philippe dallier puisque vous
êtes profession de profession
informaticien et si l'on peut se
demander est ce que le nouveau macbook
mark zuckerberg le fondateur de facebook
finalement est-ce qu'ils ne se trouvent
pas en seine-saint-denis en tout cas
tous les lycéens cette semaine de seine
saint denis vont faire un stage
d'intelligence artificielle organisé par
la région et par une association
spécialisée
l'objectif découvrir fonctionne comment
on fonctionne des programmes
informatiques et comment on peut les
rendre intelligents notamment pour
qu'ils parlent la langue des signes
également pour qu'il puisse piloter une
voiture donc voilà une immersion
informatique pour tous les lycéens de
seine saint denis merci beaucoup alex le
futur macbook air bag il en seine saint
denis pour vous fils d'allier pourquoi
pas espérons le en tous les cas on va
parler de la première actu dont on parle
et alex poussard dans sa revue de
presque
c'est cette lutte contre la vente
d'alcool la nuit et vous au scénar on le
disait vous avez lutté contre ça eh bien
écoutez j'ai j'ai obtenu un succès
effectivement avec l'élargissement des
pouvoirs de police du maire
les maires pourront effectivement fermé
jusqu'à 2 mois les établissements qui
pose des problèmes que ça soit sur des
problèmes de troubles à l'ordre public
ce qui est aux notions juridiques pas si
simple que cela à définir mais aussi en
cas d'infraction à la législation c'est
l'apport de mon amendement mais j'avais
également proposé un autre amendement
qui lui n'a pas été retenu et c'est
dommage parce que j'avais souhaité que
les maires puissent effectivement à
disposer du pouvoir de délivrer une
amende administrative de 500 euros en
cas de non respect des arrêtés du maire
notamment sur les heures de fermeture et
le paradoxe c'est que le gouvernement
m'a dit non alors qu'il a créé cette
amende administrative de 500 euros pour
tout ce qui concerne les dépôts sauvages
l'élagage et c'est donc d'un côté on m'a
dit que c'était donner trop de pouvoir
au maire alors que de l'autre côté on
les accepte
j'ai du mal à comprendre ainsi que je ne
comprends pas du tout la justification
est dès aujourd'hui je vais écrire à mes
collègues députés pour leur demander à
l'assemblée nationale de pousser cette
disposition
parce que ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que sur le terrain les choses on
n'y arrive pas les mères n'y arrive pas
et bien sûr ils sont tenues responsables
par la population des troubles qui sont
causés par ces établissements que ça
soit les épiceries qui vendent de
l'alcool ou que ça soit les bars ou les
bars à chicha qui ne ferme pas aux
horaires imposés donc il faut donner du
pouvoir aux maires et il faut devenir
efficace en fait parce qu'il faut savoir
que pour l'épicerie qui ne ferme pas ou
un bar qui ne ferme pas l'amande
aujourd'hui c'est 38 euros 38 euros et
encore il faut que le maire écrivent aux
progrès de la république et au tribunal
de police ça prend des semaines et des
semaines et dont mais c'est pas du tout
c'est absolument inefficace une amende
administrative de 500 euros j'aime
autant vous dire que celui qui ne
respecteraient pas la loi et qui
prendrait trois fois la semaine une
amende de 500 euros je pense que les
choses s'arrêterait assez vite plus
généralement sur cette loi engagement et
proximité qu'il l'examen est donc
terminée au scénar le vote aura lieu
demain est ce que pour vous c'est un
texte qui répond effectivement ce
malaise des maires c'est un texte qui a
corrigé effectivement un certain nombre
de difficultés qui était notamment issus
de tous les textes adoptés sous le
quinquennat de françois hollande
je pense que sous ce quinquennat
l'assemblée a fait le pire de ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer par parler des
intercommunalités xxl à 15000 habitants
qui a posé bien des difficultés en
province on a contraint j'allais dire le
transfert de compétences des communes
vers ces intercommunalités donc dans ce
texte on a pu corriger effectivement un
certain nombre de choses
on verra ce qu'il en reste avec
l'assemblée nationale un doute
écoutez on verra il ya un certain nombre
de modifications qui ont été apportées
par le sénat le ministre n'y était pas
favorable donc après on va voir comment
le dialogue s'instaure et puis il ya
l'autre aspect est effectivement qui
concernait le pouvoir de police des mers
et puis aussi les indemnités des maires
dans les petites communes parce que
quand vous pensez qu'il a fallu il venir
par voie d'amendement pour faire qu'un
maire qui est handicapée ne perdent pas
le bénéfice de l'allocation adulte
handicapé parce qu'il était devenu maire
enfin il y avait des choses quand même
absolument aberrante et que le sénat
essayer de corriger on va parler plus
généralement de votre département de la
seine saint denis hier il ya un an vous
étiez à matignon avec plusieurs
parlementaires de seine-saint-denis pour
dénoncer une inégalité une injustice
territoriales est ce qu'un an après vous
diriez que les choses ont avancé qu'
edouard philippe a répondu à vos
demandes
d'abord on était à matignon avec tous
les parlementaires de seine-saint-denis
de la france un soumises jusqu'au
républicains tous les parlementaires
étaient là et c'est d'ailleurs moi qui
avais pris cette initiative de demander
à rencontrer le premier ministre suit un
rapport parlementaire de l'assemblée
nationale de françois cornut gentille et
rodrigo cuando qui avait fait les avait
rendu un rapport qui pointe l état de
l'état en seine-saint-denis en matière
d'éducation de police et de justice
ce rapport est accablant on a vu le
premier ministre en septembre de l'année
dernière et il nous a demandé du temps
donc il a demandé au préfet de
seine-saint-denis de réunir les élus et
de travail et ils l'ont fait le préfet
de seine-saint-denis en juillet dernier
a rendu un rapport au premier ministre
et depuis nous attendons donc j'appelle
le premier ministre à nous recevoir à
nouveau et je l'appelle surtout à
prendre des décisions
parce qu'il faut bien se rendre compte
que ce département ne s'en sortira pas
si l'état n'y revient pas de manière
très forte en matière d'éducation je
vais pas revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
encore récemment dans ce département
mais il nous faut aussi des moyens
beaucoup plus importants ou tribune
de bobigny comme dans nos commissariats
si la république ne revient pas dans ce
département à la hauteur de nos
problèmes et bien ce département partira
définitivement à la dérive
et ça je ne peux pas les coûts vont
partir à la dérive qu'est ce que ça peut
entraîner c'est que c'est qu'on a des
quartiers qui sont déjà des quartiers
qui se sont éloignés de la république
mais c'est un département tout entier
qui est un glissé imaginer que on nous
dit qu'il ya un million six cent mille
habitants seine-saint-denis la réalité
c'est probablement plus près de 2
millions où il y aurait entre trois et
quatre cent mille clandestins
comment voulez vous qu'on arrive à gérer
les problèmes de ce département quand on
est dans une situation pareille
donc il faut que ça s'arrête et il faut
que le gouvernement prenne ses
responsabilités donc on entend votre
appel à edouard philippe vous demander
des réponses ou demander des mesures des
actes
merci beaucoup fils d'ali et merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce